deuxième tour des élections cantonales
les abstentionnistes sont encore plus
nombreux qu'au premier à 17 heures
dernier pourcentage 39 points 46 fond de
votre temps ils étaient 42 % dimanche
dernier
entretiens de bichat comment réintégrer
les malades guéri d'un cancer d'abord en
demandant aux assurances et aux banques
de les considérer comme des citoyens
ordinaires obélix et astérix en chair et
en os au cirque d'hiver un pari santé
par jérôme savary qui a reconstitué sur
scène ce petit village gaulois qui
n'accepte pas la domination romaine
madame monsieur bonsoir c'est le sort
d'un homme et d'un peuple qui se jouera
mercredi prochain au chili d'un côté un
dictateur le général pinochet au pouvoir
depuis 15 ans et qui par un plébiscite
demande aux chiliens de lui faire
confiance pour cette année encore de
l'autre une opposition grandissante qui
hier soir a réussi à faire descendre
environ un million de personnes dans les
rues de la capitale santiago du chili
bernard benyamin pascal c'est à la fin
pas bien et il suit cent mille 1 million
un million deux cent mille cette filière
à santiago assez grande manifestation
jamais réalisée en chine
il était là pour dire non au général
pinochet
tout ce que le chimique ou darty
s'étaient retrouvés sur l'immense elle
tous d'accord pour reprendre le slogan
de cette fin de campagne du non
l'alegria y aviez mais c'est à dire la
joie à venir
et c'est sans doute le point essentiel
de cette manifestation pour la première
fois depuis 15 ans des chiliens
d'opposition sont descendus dans la rue
et non pas avec la peur au ventre mais
pour laisser éclater leur joie
ce matin c'était au tour des partisans
d'une wii d'envahir le centre de
santiago une énorme caravane genève et
vaud par trier a rapidement paralysé
toute la circulation pour apporter son
soutien en général pinochet
plusieurs dizaines de milliers de
personnes ont ainsi défilé pendant
quatre heures sur l'alameda je prends
toutes leurs forces dans cette dernière
bataille avant le publiciste
ce soir la campagne électorale sera donc
officiellement terminée et mercredi les
chiliens décideront si oui ou non ils
veulent du général pinochet
jusqu'en 1997 si le rouge encore rien ne
change
mais si c'est le nom qui gagne comme
semblent l'indiquer les tout derniers
s'engagent et bien la constitution
prévoit la tenue d'élections
présidentielles d'ici un an
dans ce cas le chili pourrait bien
entrer dans une période riche en
rebondissements
4 informations de l'étranger encore est
d'abord deux nouveaux otages à kaboul en
afghanistan un docteur et une infirmière
d'origine allemande de l'organisation
médecins du monde qui vient d'ailleurs
de créer un comité de soutien en leur
faveur ils sont accusés d'espionnage et
de coopération avec la rébellion pour
l'instant ils n'ont pu recevoir aucune
visite de représentants de leur
ambassade dans la capitale de
l'afghanistan état critique pour franz
josef strauss l'homme politique ouest
allemand qui lutte actuellement contre
la mort dans un hôpital de munich en
bavière
victime il hier d'un très grave malaise
carte suite du quiproquo du véritable
quiproquo entre le président du zaïre
monsieur mobutu et celui d'afrique du
sud monsieur botha
les deux hommes se sont rencontrés hier
monsieur mobutu est persuadé d'avoir
compris que le leader nationaliste noir
nelson mandela allait être libéré sans
condition
l'afrique du sud continue elle de
démentis et puis on est peut-être à 48
heures d'un événement majeur en afrique
la reprise des relations diplomatiques
entre la libye et le tchad ennemis
d'hier retour en france avec un sujet
terre-à-terre mais qui a son importance
dans le cadre de notre confort de vie ce
dimanche deux grands magasins
d'ameublement et de bricolage avait
décidé d'ouvrir leurs portes
et cela malgré une récente décision de
justice suite à une plainte du syndicat
cgt et condamnant ces entreprises à une
amende de 200 mille francs
chaque fois qu'elle dérogerait à la
règle de la fermeture hebdomadaire du
dimanche
mais pour ces sociétés transgresser la
règle vaut la peine nicolas jacobs
france brice ouvert le dimanche c'est
écrit à l'entrée et la direction d'ikea
ainsi tient le magasin d'evry en
banlieue parisienne était ouvert aux
aujourd'hui malgré le refus du préfet
d'accorder les dérogations nécessaires
et malgré la condamnation par la justice
au paiement d'une astreinte de 200 mille
francs
mais pour la direction pas question de
fermer la porte aux 9000 clients qui
affluent chaque dimanche jour de repos
ou non ce sont trois millions de francs
qui restent dans les caisses pour
l'instant ont fait 28 % de notre chiffre
d'affaires le dimanche c'est un client
particulier qui vient le dimanche qui
vient de loin qui va pas revenir lundi
ou mardi et peut-être le samedi mais le
samedi on a deux chats satura ici vous
risquez donc de payer une astreinte de
200 mille francs
oui pour l'instant on prend le risque et
la direction de brandir la suppression
de 60 emplois sur 280 parmi ceux-ci
beaucoup d'étudiants dont les heures de
travail dominical sont payés double pour
les autres les salariés une prime de 800
francs par mois et la récupération des
jours travaillés en moyenne de dimanche
sur 5 le jour où j'ai postulé pour
contrer dans cette société
maintenant on
le fait de travailler dimanche faisait
partie de mon travail puisque le magasin
ouvre le dimanche
quand on vendeur
rappel à travailler c'est dimanche ça ne
me dérangeait pas d'autant plus aux
compensations financières à quelques
kilomètres de là une autre grande
surface leroy merlin est dans la même
situation
et là aussi on a décidé de passer outre
de rester ouverts le dimanche et
d'engager ainsi un bras de fer avec
l'administration et la cgt problèmes
quotidiens encore à paris viennent de se
terminer les entretiens médicaux de
bichat avec un sujet qui n'est pas
strictement médical mais qui a son
importance beaucoup d'importance même
les malades guéri d'un cancer et ils
sont de plus en plus nombreux ont ils le
droit d'être traités en citoyens
ordinaires
et bien apparemment non car les banques
et les assurances continuent de les
considérer comme des malades et en
conséquence de leur refuser une partie
de leurs services
jean daniel flaysakier maryse aïcha
quand un appartement s'est libéré au
sixième étage de cet immeuble
dominique fable et a saisi l'aubaine son
plan épargne logement était arrivé à
échéance et rien de s'opposer à l'achat
et dominique avait oublié un détail
trois ans auparavant il avait été prêté
est guéri d'une forme de cancer appelée
maladie de hodgkin pour lui c'était le
passé mais pour ceux qui lui prêter
l'argent pas vraiment j'ai donc
découvert un questionnaire
posant évidemment toutes les questions
relatives fin j'ai tout de suite détecté
comme étant relative aux cancers
puisqu'il ne nous demandait si j'avais
subi des des traitements de
chimiothérapie ou de radiothérapie est
ce que trois ou quatre ans après la fin
de votre traitement trois ou quatre ans
après votre guérison vous aviez
l'impression de replonger dans la
maladie avec ce questionnaire oui c'est
un effet inévitable quand ça vous arrive
je dirais comme ça sans l'avoir prévu du
tout bien évidemment et vous vous dites
mais à quoi ça cela signifie
d'autant que vous êtes persuadé que en
plus cette forme de maladie qui est la
maladie d'hodgkin est complètement guéri
sable le cas de dominique fable et a été
examinée favorablement par des experts
réassureur comme ceux ci les médecins et
des tarificateur qui décide d'accepter
ou de refuser un dossier et cela au vu
de données scientifiques récentes ont
guéri en effet aujourd'hui de plus en
plus de cancers et pour certaines
atteintes après quelques années
difficiles
l'espérance de vie est semblable à celle
de la population générale pour d'autres
hélas le refus d'assurer étape son
exclusion malheureusement il en existe
mais ce sont les cancers de mauvais
pronostic dont on sait pertinemment que
le risque de décès est important on
pourrait effectivement les tarifs et
mais leur proposerait alors des
surprimes tellement énorme qu'il
refuserait devant l'importance de la
somme à verser par contre les autres
formes plus bénignes comme on a dit le
cancer du sein la maladie de hodgkin les
cancers du testicule ceux là on les
assure soit éventuellement à risque
normal lorsqu'on est sûr qu'ils sont
guéris soit avec une surprime qui peut
durer quelques années voire davantage
au-delà de l'aspect financier il ya un
point essentiel a souligné le respect
absolu du secret médical
seul le médecin de la compagnie
d'assurance doit avoir à connaître du
diagnostic pour lequel j'ai surpris mes
demandes et personne d'autre du pdg à
l'employé de base ne doit savoir une
notion qu'il n'est pas inutile de
rappeler la politique sujet unique
aujourd'hui élections cantonales bien le
résultat le plus important est déjà
connue c'est celui du pourcentage des
votants à 17h il était de -2 40%
le 46 très exactement c'est encore moins
que dimanche dernier jean louis la scène
au ministère de l'intérieur avec les
derniers chiffres chambry oui
effectivement daniel dernier chiffre
officiel de participation connu ici au
ministère de l'intérieur celui 17 heures
confirme donc la tendance de la semaine
dernière et celle de 12h à 17h 39,46 %
seulement des électeurs s'étaient
déplacés pour aller voter ce qui
représente plus de deux points et demi
de moins que la semaine dernière à la
même heure qui pourtant avait connu un
record historique d'abstention
et si on compare avec le chiffre des
cantonales 82 ce n'est plus un écart
c'est un gouffre dix huit et demi pour
cent d'électeurs en moins il est vrai
que dans 88 cantons sur les 11 138
concernés par le scrutin d'aujourd'hui
il ne restait qu'un seul et unique
candidat ce qui n'est pas fait pour
inciter à aller voter
il est vrai aussi que cette fois un
leader politique jean-marie le pen avait
appelé ses électeurs à bouder les urnes
mais ceci ne peut pas entièrement
expliquer cela alors ras-le-bol des
élections à répétition ou plus crûment
ras-le-bol de la classe politique dans
son ensemble
il faudra en tout cas beaucoup de
discernement pour tirer les conclusions
d'un scrutin qui a si peu motivés les
français alors que paradoxalement depuis
la loi de décentralisation de 1982
le conseil général est devenu un des
rouages essentiels de la république
merci jean louis un premier commentaire
politique tout de suite
gilles leclair que nous rejoignons dans
notre studio aura lieu à partir de 22h15
notre émission spéciale cantonales alors
gilles ce dont on va le plus parler ce
soir ce n'est pas des élus finalement ça
va être des électeurs
oui on se dirige sans doute vers un taux
d'abstention record ce soir qui va tout
à l'heure alimenter sans aucun doute
l'essentiel des débats et des
commentaires même si l'analyse sur le
faible taux de participation restera
sans doute le même que dimanche dernier
à savoir la lassitude des électeurs en
france le manque d'enjeu politique
claire l'absence de mobilisation forte
dans les deux entre les deux tours dans
les deux camps mais ce soir nous
essaierons tout même de tirer quelques
enseignements politiques de ce second
tour des cantonales
en examinant d'abord le rapport de force
droite gauche
malgré les discours sur l'ouverture en
effet il
j en ai fait une nouvelle fois
aujourd'hui d'une élection disons
classique avec un affrontement dans la
plupart des cas entre la droite et la
gauche alors qu'elles seront tous même
les politiques pour essayer de bien
comprendre ce second tour
au moins deux clés d'abord nous
regarderons nous examinerons les reports
de voix du front national malgré les
consignes de jean marie le pen
ensuite nous examinerons de très près la
discipline au sein de la gauche pour
examiner les rapports entre le ps et le
parti communiste enfin bien sûr nous
suivrons de très près les départements
qui risque peut-être de basculer ce soir
dans le sens droite gauche ou dans le
sens gauche droite mais bien entendu
nous examinerons surtout donc et tous
les débats tourneront autour de cette
question du très faible taux de
participation ce soir ce sera sans aucun
doute l'essentiel des débats merci
gilles alors justement nous allons les
faire un rapide tour en province d'abord
grenoble pascal remy à grenoble avec des
résultats déjà et importe quoi oui bon
sens d'ailleurs je viens de recevoir les
dix premiers cantons qui ont été pourvus
alors si je revienne à la droite et
quatre reviennent à la gauche le sort de
venette nationale est d'ores et déjà
réglée il s'agit d'haroun tazieff que
l'on ne présente plus haroun tazieff qui
a été brillamment élu avec 55% des voix
contre le docteur pierre fugain qui lui
était soutenu par le ps mais qui était
également un candidat d'ouverture
quant à edvige avice qui est député
socialiste de l'isère qui est secrétaire
d'état dans le gouvernement rocard et
bien elle a été battue mais il est
encore trop tôt pour vous dire pour nous
dire si le département a basculé de la
droite vers la gauche ou bien ce qui
paraît quand même le plus probable s'il
reste du côté du rpr on a senti
aujourd'hui comme un frémissement du
côté des isoloirs le taux de
participation était très légèrement mais
légèrement quand même plus élevée que
dimanche dernier c'est à dire que les
électeurs ont davantage voté dans les
cantons les plus disputées les cantons
les plus chauds l'enjeu je vous le
rappelle est très important c'est
carrément la présidence du conseil
général c'est à dire la couleur
politique du département
il y as 22 cantons qui reste en balance
et dans près de la moitié d'entre eux la
lutte est très serrée tout se jouera à
quelques voix près le verdict devrait
tomber dans environ une heure quand nous
aurons tous les résultats bureau de vote
par bureau de vote
on peut faire en tout cas un premier
constat à 20h15 c'est que l'ouverture
n'a pas vraiment fait recette dans
l'isère la seule exception la règle
c'est haroun tazieff jeu
dick a été brillamment élu mais c'est le
seul candidat de la société civile à
avoir vraiment tirer son épingle du jeu
les autres sont des faits ce soir alors
on en est revenu au fil des jours un
schéma plutôt connu un schéma plutôt
classique celui de l'affrontement
droite-gauche l'isère qualifié de
laboratoires de l'ouverture n'a donc pas
vraiment tenu ses promesses
merci pascal à vol d'oiseau télévisée
deux secondes maintenant pour nous
rendre de grenoble à marseille olivier
lerner l'assaut crois qu'on a atteint un
taux de participation le plus faible
jamais connu à marseille
absolument mais un rappel tout d'abord
avec le recul du front national et la
remontée du parti communiste et bien sûr
une très forte abstention ici dans les
bouches-du-rhône tel était pour ce mode
et les trois enseignements que nous
avions ont tiré au soir du premier tour
ce soir il est encore trop tôt
évidemment pour confirmer ces
informations en bloc cependant sur le
taux de participation donc je peux
toutefois vous confirmer le vote
confidentiel des marseillais c'est le
moins que l'on puisse dire on atteint
ici un taux record d'abstention avec -2
32% un des lecteurs sur trois donc ces
déplacés d'ici dans les bouches du rhône
seule incertitude ici la bataille
semblait jouée d'avancé bien le 4e
canton bernard mas novelli un divers
droite est en ballottage favorable
contre le socialiste jean-jacques
leonetti dans un quartier
traditionnellement ancré à gauche
ma novelli l'aurait emporté cette
information est encore à me mettre au
conditionnel avec 193 voix d'avancé en
attendant le choc des titans pour bien
sûr les municipales marseille se
contente de ce que l'on pourrait appeler
des deuxièmes couteaux
en cela le taux record de non
participation est une bonne leçon pour
les futurs candidats au siège de maire
de marseille voilà les municipales dont
tu
merci olivier merci messieurs on vous
retrouve donc bien sûr tout à l'heure à
22h15 à partir de 22h15 pour la soirée
spéciale élections cantonales donc j'ai
décidé de ne pas rester en route mois si
la politique ne passionne pas toujours
les français voilà un sujet qui lui les
passionne en permanence au pays de la
maison individuelle en effet l ouverture
du salon annuel à paris et toujours un
événement cette année le syndicat des
constructeurs a décidé de faire le
ménage dans la profession en imposant à
ses adhérents une caution de garantie
bancaire indispensable à la tranquillité
des acheteurs en effet
faut savoir que l'an dernier 87 donc
quatre mille chantiers ont été
interrompues en france par la faute
d'entreprises défaillantes engendrant
bien entendu des difficultés et des
frais supplémentaires pour les acteurs
jean pellieux yanncik c'était hlm les
sifflets repenser bien la quitte et
quand ils décident des bus 87 de se
faire construire une maison
mais les choses tournent mal c'était il
ya un an le chantier n'avance pas la
tempête frappe la région les murs
s'effondrent le constructeur va réparer
pensent les six faire non pas le leur il
a déposé son bilan la famille saisi la
justice
on découvre que le contrat était passé
non pas avec le gérant mais un
mandataire
il est sans valeur quant au gérant il a
disparu
les sifflets qui ont déboursé plus de
500 mille francs banque loyer avocat et
cetera ont tout perdu il s'avère que le
constructeur qui sous-traitait tous ces
travaux à des sous traitants n'a
absolument pas surveiller le travail de
son sous-traitant principal je lui ai
demandé s'il avait une garantie bancaire
il m'a répondu que ça servait à rien
parce que les paiements étaient faits au
fur à vivre cette garantie bancaire ou
caution financière d'achèvement va être
rendu obligatoire par l'union des
constructeurs
elle coûte 0 30% du prix de la maison en
cas de défaillances la banque ou
l'assurance qu'ils accordent fait
poursuivre le chantier par d'autres
entreprises
c'est effectivement un problème de
moralisation la garantie extrinsèque ou
nouvellement appelée caution financière
d'achèvement est donné par un élément
extérieur à l'entreprise qui donc à un
droits indirects de regard sur la
gestion d'entreprise le conteneur en
effet élimine les incompétents et les
filous certes les adhérents à l'union
des constructeurs ne livre qu'un tiers
des maisons mais grâce au jeu de la
concurrence la caution devrait s'étendre
et éviter que le rêve d'une maison ne se
transforme en cauchemar
à partir de demain une partie de la loi
ce gain le ministre l'ex ministre de
jacques chirac qui avait réduit les
remboursements de certains médicaments
pour rétablir les finances de
l'assurance maladie en france c'est bien
une partie de cette loi est annulé et
cela concerne principalement les
maladies de longue durée au nombre de
trente très exactement
les médicaments dits de confort
nécessaire à leur traitement vont donc
être à nouveau remboursées à 100 % au
lieu de 40 précédemment
voilà encore un sujet sur lequel tous
les français sont d'accord et qui les
intéresse est même d'accord leurs hommes
politiques
il s'agit de l'éducation qui doit être
nous dit-on la priorité des priorités
c'est la vraie richesse naturelle de la
france en conséquence et bien le
ministère de l'éducation nationale va
s'afficher publicité sur les murs de
tout le pays pour recruter des
enseignants qui font cruellement défaut
vous le savez mais on le sait également
sans revalorisation des salaires
on ne peut espérer un renouveau des
vocations et l'attrait des vacances
n'est pas un argument vraiment sérieux a
opposé à cette nécessité
écoutez plutôt ces témoignages d'un
professeur qui nous explique simplement
très simplement d'ailleurs sans aigreur
sa situation serge me serais pas ce
cardiologue françois tesson à 36 ans
parisien il enseigne en banlieue au
lycée louise-michel à champigny prof de
maths certifié de sixième échelon il
progresse dans sa profession à
l'ancienneté
comme beaucoup de ses confrères entre
lui et son métier c'est d'une certaine
manière une histoire d'amour
c'est un métier qui m'a que j'ai
entièrement découvert j'avais pas ce
qu'on appelle la vocation
j'ai entièrement découvert j'étais j'ai
découvert c'était intéressant c'était un
métier assez dynamique
mais par moments je me dis que je suis
un peu dans une ornière aussi serre que
je bon j'ai voulu être prof et je
resterai certainement profonde jusqu'à
la fin de ma vie et que je me choque les
roses un peu mince carreau c'est la
hantise de tous les propres 18 heures de
cours par semaine les mêmes cours n'est
que la surcharge et les mêmes choses
tous les jours une vie rythmée par les
sonneries toutes les heures les conseils
de classe et le métier toujours le même
métier une classe on peut pas arriver en
disant aujourd'hui je vais pas
travailler qu'une classe à elle est
devant vous il faut travailler et à la
limite c'est souvent eux qui sans savoir
qu'on va mal de fête réconforte et c'est
la classe qui vous portent quelque part
jamila métier vous gagnez combien par
mois au moins au point de vue salaire au
passé simple hein ça tourne autour de
9000 francs en fin de 9000 louis autour
d'une famille j'ai ma fiche de paye
y'a pas de secret la voilà que là
c'était 2009 1200 francs et bon bah je
peux espérer
on est à 9 mille deux cents francs net
et je peux espérer qu'ils ont douze
mille 5 à la fin de ma carrière
dans combien de temps maintenant disons
une vingtaine d'années une profession à
l'évidence dévaloriser affirme utile
comme beaucoup de ses confrères
dévaloriser c'est certainement quand
j'en parle des amis bon on peut en faire
un tour de table avec son informatique
il y en a qui sont dans le marketing
mois un pro pour sa part de souris on
est assis république
on est face à des jeunes et et un bon
ben on sait très bien que on fera le
maximum pour enfin a priori abus donc
oui à bulle certainement grâce au
ras-le-bol dont les pouvoirs publics
devront tenir compte surtout dans le
climat social actuel pour les
enseignants entre l'argent et la gloire
le choix de liens chaque vous plus
évident sport c'est fini la délégation
française revient avec 16 médailles la
dernière est en or elle a été remportée
par le cavalier pierre durand et son
cheval à ne pas oublier jappeloup dans
l'épreuve du saut d'obstacles et puis ce
fut la cérémonie de clôture où il
n'était plus question de performance ni
d'adversaire la fête à laquelle
l'essentiel comme disait coubertin était
de participer tous les bars une flamme
qui s'éteint tout doucement sur le stade
olympique
un au revoir géant de tout le peuple sud
coréen un drapeau annonçant déjà
barcelone 1992 ça y est les 21e jeux
olympiques sont bel et bien terminées
quinze jours de joie de déception quinze
jours d'exploit de contre-performances
aussi quinze jours placée sous la devise
paix harmonie progrès le progrès c'est
peut-être d'avoir effectué un contrôle
anti dopage sans précédent des athlètes
des classes et des stars même d'autres
soupçonné et un esprit olympique peut
être un peu bafouée l'harmonie c'est
sans doute d'avoir réuni 160 et une
nation chose qui n'était pas arrivé
depuis 72 munich
enfin la paix c'est sûrement d'avoir
protégé ses jeux contre tout problème
interne au pays ou externe avec le
voisin du nord séoul 88 c'est donc fini
chacun fait ses valises et repart chez
lui la tête pleine de grands souvenirs
et de belles images
rendez vous dans quatre ans d'ici là les
photos ronge
formidable alain prost vainqueur cet
après-midi du grand prix d'espagne de
formule 1 en tête du championnat du
monde des pilotes et qui a toutes ses
chances qui a retrouvé toutes ses
chances de remporter une troisième fois
le titre
francis maroteaux 14e grand prix de la
saison 11e pole position pour ayrton
senna juste derrière le brésilien alain
prost mais le français ne restera que
200 m derrière premier virage prost
devant et surprise mansell passe
également sénat d'entrée la logique est
bousculé bousculer aussi rené arnoux
résultats abandon nous français course
termine course qui commence en revanche
entre mansell et senna le brésilien
passe en anglais mais mende ça lui
refait l'intérieur
la méthode prost a fait école derrière
prost et mansell la résistance
s'organise le plus acharné à leur perte
ivan capelli l'italien chasse derrière
senna est un peu plus tard il chasse le
brésilien
les quelques tours plus loin le moteur
de capelli part en fumée
entre-temps prost change de pneus mais
son avance est telle que la victoire ne
fait plus de doute prost relancer pour
la course au titre est super c'est
encore une fois comme je l'aï dit tout
les années pratiquement d'aller d'aller
pour la tournée
japon australie avec encore une petite
chance de champion du monde mais j'ai
gagné six courses cette année pour moi
c'est ce qui viendra presse étant tenue
c'est déjà super puce - superbe la
performance daheron sénat 7e qui passe
burger tout d'abord puis patrese
finalement le brésilien termine 4ème de
ce grand prix d'espagne
prost premier donc deuxième nigel
mansell et 3e alessandro nannini au
classement général le français avec 84
points comptent cinq points d'avancé sur
le brésilien
mais surtout il est revenu à une
victoire de senna à deux grands prix de
la fin
spectacle depuis que rené goscinny et
albert uderzo ont inventé astérix et
obélix et de gaulois sont véritablement
devenu l'image symbole des français
remplaçant ainsi le béret basque et la
baguette de pain sous le bras
personnage de bande dessinée vendus à
des dizaines de millions d'exemplaires
avant de devenir des héros de dessin
animé
il se retrouve aujourd'hui en chair et
en os au cirque d'hiver à paris en
compagnie de tout leur petit monde 40
comédiens cascadeurs un chien quatre
sangliers quatre chevaux un éléphant des
poules et des canards
tous habitants de ce petit village qui
n'accepte pas la domination romaine
obélix et astérix sur scène c'est un
pari que tant de jérôme savary
nicole corner langlois claude sicard
puis s'en fous ces gaulois ils viennent
d'installer leur village au point de
chaume au cirque d'hiver
avec leurs chansons dans ces bagarres
ils font exploser la bande dessinée les
cohortes de romain stupide départ et se
défile tandis que les gaulois eux font
la fête
aidés par leurs potions célèbre et un
orchestre contemporain
ritz ashkan onyx obélie et les autres
existent grâce au talent d'un magicien
vigilant quoi être vraiment rester très
fidèle à la bd ce que je peux dire c'est
que peut-être que la bd est un peu
savent aryenne faut pas oublier que
goscinny a été le père spirituel de
toute une génération qui est la mienne
la génération des sixties comme on dit
les gotlib les réserves les léventins ce
qui est
et finalement je me retrouve dans dans
l'humour de goscinny je n'ai donc pas eu
vraiment besoin de vraiment besoin de
rajouter quoi que ce soit je pense que
90% du texte du spectacle astérix et du
texte original de goscinny de toutes les
bandes dessinées que je connais c'est
celle qui me semble la plus apte à
pellets en même temps aux enfants et aux
adultes
rires expulsions n'ont rien nouveau ah
si j'oubliais j'ai assumé une patrouille
romaine dans la clairière d'état remue
pas bon tu viens manger le 100 me avec
moi je re lieu dans quelques instants
j'ai encore du menhir libre lune
et j'ai pas formidable
à
simple et drôle pour les enfants le
spectacle devient sophistiqués pour les
adultes le tiercé cet après midi à
longchamp dans le grand prix de l'arc de
triomphe et le cheval italien toni been
qui avait avalé la potion magique et qui
a remporté le 67e prix de l'arc de
triomphe cet après midi à longchamp donc
devant le cheval britannique ni auto et
le français boissinot cette course
servait de support au tiercé aux cartes
et on voit si les rapports qui s'affiche
sur votre écran d'excellents rapports
13000 un peu plus de 13 mille francs
pour le tiercé est un peu plus de 243
milles francs pour ce qui concerne le
carpe et j'espère que vous avez gagné
voilà je suis en tout cas que vous
gagnerez ce soir à nous regarder car à
partir de 22h15 vous pourrez suivre sur
notre chaîne sur antenne 2 une émission
spéciale consacrée aux élections
cantonales émission spéciale que nous
présentent toutes une courte série ans
claude oui daniel vous serrez que le
slogan principal d'antenne de s'allumer
la passion nous essaierons malgré le
taux fort d'abstention de rallumer la
pression pour les débats politiques nous
aurons pour cela sur ce plateau maxime
gremetz du parti communiste pierre
mauroy alain juppé pierre méhaignerie
gérard longuet jean claude martinez
proches jean-marie le pen
voilà pour le débat politique et puis
ici nous avons fait comme d'habitude
lors de soirées électorales nous avons
mobilisé toute la rédaction d'antenne 2
avec caen rien stamm berne accouche d'un
guéridon qui était aux commandes le
réalisateur et puis avec gilles leclair
albert du roy bernard pradines haut et
toute la rédaction se mobilise et comme
vous avez l'habitude vous
téléspectateurs de suivre les élections
sur antenne 2 nous essaierons de faire
des points en province je vous dis tout
de suite il ya pas franchement une
surprise parmi les premiers résultats
que nous avons mais nous essaierons de
faire le point sur ces élections si
leclerc évoqué le problème de ce scrutin
qui n'a pas été suivie par les français
mais ne débattront du regroupement
peut-être de ce scrutin du mode de
scrutin pour les années à venir et puis
du vrai débat politique qui est ainsi
lancé par les électeurs
est ce que c'est et on était vraiment
concernés est ce qu'ils savent à quoi
sert un conseil général or tous cas nous
ferons partir de 22h10 il y à une note
d'humour c'est le titre du téléfilm qui
nous précèdent race s'appelle fausses
notes nous essaierons de ne pas en faire
tout à l'heure à partir de 22 heures
merci claude et je voudrais moi vous
rappeler à titre personnel que
souvenez-vous aux présidentielles et
ensuite aux législatives où nous avait
été largement fidèles et vous verrez que
contrairement à ce que disent certains
ce soir nous sommes encore là et bien là
vous pouvez nous faire confiance
voilà après cette édition spéciale
élections vous pourrez suivre le dernier
journal présenté par philippe gassot
demain matin premier rendez vous avec
l'information télématin 6h45 et puis
demain soir à 20 heures
vous retrouverez ici même christine
okrent un bon soir excellente semaine à
samedi prochain